everybody thinks that World War II is
about to break out and it looks like it
already has to be honest so where is the
best place to store your money you need
a safe haven asset I always say Bitcoin
is the best place during times of Global
Financial instability because think
about what happens in a war it's a World
War so we need an asset which isn't
subject to any specific jurisdiction we
don't know what these countries are
going to do we don't know what different
emergency laws or emergency powers are
going to be implemented and so we
desperately need money which is fully
decentralized and Bitcoin is and also
Bitcoin has stood the test of time we've
seen how resilient it's been throughout
the flu and the lockdowns and the force
injections then we had the riots and
then we had the war with Russia and
Ukraine there's been so much going on
and yet Bitcoin has still managed to
prove itself and actually perform very
well